aux droits fondamentaux sont ils en
danger c'est ce qu'affirme jacques
toubon dans son dernier livre avant d'en
débattre on liste avec jérémy huntsman
les lois récentes qui ont bousculé nos
libertés de public
d'un état d'urgence à l'autre les
libertés publiques ont elles régressé en
france en novembre 2015 au lendemain des
attentats de paris l'état d'urgence est
déclaré par françois hollande pour
lutter contre le risque terroriste
prolonger plusieurs fois ces
dispositions entrent dans le droit
commun deux ans plus tard en 2017 avec
la fermeture administrative des lieux de
culte par exemple des mesures de
surveillance renforcée tout comme les
perquisitions et assignation à résidence
sous le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
plusieurs lois vont ensuite faire
polémique
la loi sur le secret des affaires en
2018 la loi dite anti casseur de 2019
pendant la crise des gilet jaune la loi
sécurité globale et son article 24
visant à limiter la diffusion d'image de
policiers des textes très critiqué mais
jugée nécessaire par la droite
sénatoriale la sécurité l'insécurité
d'ailleurs est un problème permanent en
france depuis déjà dix quinze ans et
c'est un problème qui ne fait que
s'accroître donc je pense même pour être
tout à fait franc que on est encore pas
allé assez loin en matière de sécurité
en mars 2020 l'état d'urgence sanitaire
est décrété pour faire face à la
pandémie de kovy 19 il prévoit la
limitation de la liberté d'aller et
venir avec le confinement et le
couvre-feu et permet la réquisition de
biens et services ou le contrôle des
prix des mesures prises par décret par
le premier ministre souvent sans l'aval
du parlement comme le regrette la gauche
du sénat qui devra premières libertés
publiques que chez celles des
représentants
des citoyens combien de fois notre
parlement a été maltraité multiplication
des ordonnances textes toujours passer
en urgence pour des raisons d'affichage
sécurité eh bien on a été très très loin
dans ce quinquennat et pour un résultat
quand même assez médiocre la masia
plusieurs dispositions notamment la
possibilité de recourir au pass
sanitaires sont encore en vigueur
jusqu'au 31 juillet
nos droits fondamentaux sont ils en
danger voilà le thème de notre débat
dans ce sens public et j'accueille
jacques toubon bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes ancien ministre de la justice
en simili de la culture ancien défenseur
des droits et vous publiez donc se dit
ce livre je dois vous dire c'est aux
éditions stock et c'est votre livre qui
nous a donné envie d'organiser ce ce
débat j'accueille également anne
charlotte bezina bonsoir charlène
bienvenue maître de conférences en droit
public
hervé le bras devant soir bienvenue soit
vous êtes démographe historien directeur
d'études à l'école des hautes études en
sciences sociales et chercheur émérite à
l'institut national d'études
démographiques les dix siècles pas et
historique politique et rester à mes
côtés jacques toubon vous écrivez donc
que nos droits fondamentaux sont en sont
en danger de quand date cette dérive ou
pour moi parce que mon lio n'est pas un
livre d'actualité même si il ya beaucoup
de choses qui peuvent
sembler sera portée à la campagne
présidentielle ou législative et même si
une sur votre façon l'éclatement de la
guerre entre entre la russie et
l'ukraine est une espèce de
manifestations de ce que j'ai essayé de
deux d'expliquer et qui se passe en
france et qui se passe aussi au brésil
en gris et même de manière étonnante
dans certains pays comme la hollande ou
au danemark qui sont réputés pour être
plus démocratique que moi tu meurs et et
qui se laissent aller à des sortes de
comportements politiques de mesures
législatives
d'organisations gouvernementales qu'on
peut qualifier c'est le mot qu'on
emploie aujourd'hui 2 il libéral c'est
pour ça qu'on a à faire c'est sorte de
démocratie libérale ou d'autocratie
élective on peut le dire aussi comme ça
le plus bel exemple est naturellement la
hongrie monsieur or ban se fait réélire
toujours avec des majorités de plus en
plus forte pour prendre des mesures
toujours plus anti démocratique
c'est-à-dire contraire au droit aux
droits fondamentaux que ce soit la
dépendance de la justice que ce soit la
liberté de la presse et à et c'est ça
qui me bousquet et pour répondre à votre
question moi je pense que le grand
tournant ce a probablement été le la
faire des tours jumelles long c'est à
dire c'est à dire le 11 septembre quand
les américains se sont aperçus qu'il y
avait aucune partie de la terre qui
pouvait échapper à l'insécurité au
terrorisme y compris le territoire des
etats-unis et qu' ils ont lancé une loi
qui s'appelait le patriot act tout le
monde dans l'hémisphère nord a fait à un
moment ou un autre un ou des patriot act
quelquefois un peu plus fort quelquefois
un peu moins fort mais partout et c'est
là dedans que son contenu cette espèce
des quais contenu cette espèce d'érosion
des droits fondamentaux et j'ajoute que
dans mon bouquin
le le phénomène de base qui conduit
cette horreur de troubles mentaux c'est
naturellement le développement des
identitarisme c'est à dire de toutes ces
comportements qui font que dont toi toi
tu n'es pas comme moi on est différent
mais cette différence comme les valeurs
universelles des droits fondamentaux
nous le commande depuis 250 ans elle ne
conduit pas à ce que nous soyons inégaux
et à ce que toi tu sois supérieur à moi
ou inversement non ça c'est depuis 250
ans on a admis qu' il y avait 7
milliards et demi de personnes à la
surface de la terre et qu' ils étaient
tous égaux ils avaient tous la même
dignité tout en étant différent
il s'agit de savoir quel genre de
différence mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
les différences sont utilisés pour
diviser
et nous nous trouvons dans une situation
où
l'égalité qui est mise en cause c'est
une égalité qui rassemble c'est
l'égalité qui rassemble et qui est mise
en cause aujourd'hui et moi je l' ai
bien vu en particulier dans mon explique
dans mon expérience de défenseur des
droits puisque le défenseur des droits
est notamment chargé de la lutte contre
les discriminations sur le plan
juridique avec les tribunaux bien
entendu qui tranchent toujours et je me
suis bien rendu compte que nous étions
dans les situations de plus en plus
qu'il était considéré que que ce soit
pour la couleur de peau que ce soit le
logement on est que ce soit l'endroit où
on habite que ce soit l'endroit d'où on
vient que ce soit la religion qu'on
pratique on s'enferme l'ange une
identité alors cette identité ce n'est
qu'en la main dit et qui participe à la
citoyenneté oui mais qui au contraire ou
alors je vous ai laissé longuement posé
dans les enjeux mais c'était passionnant
parce que c'est ce sont les grands
thèmes qu'on va explorer évidemment dans
pendant ce débat je reprends votre date
de démarrage en quelque sorte en
l'occurrence le 11 septembre aux états
unis mais amsterdam bezina est ce que si
on se rapporte à notre situation est ce
qu'on peut dire en france depuis les
attentats 2015 on vit dans une sorte
d'état d'urgence permanent finalement
bien sûr on doit le dire d'ailleurs il y
à une menace sur nos libertés qui est
celle de deux l'exception qui est celle
de la sécurité et c'est vrai qu'à partir
du moment où un peuple a peur à un
peuple a besoin de sécurité et bien il
va observer une période de repli et la
législation va servir à devenir une
espèce de boucliers à toutes les menaces
mais le droit n'est pas fait pour ça et
l'état d'exception justement aujourd'hui
est assimilé à l'état de crise et donc
dès qu'on rencontre une nouvelle crise
eh bien on crée une nouvelle exception
comme si finalement de se faciliter
poteau c'est une phase i dans la
réparation aussi et peut-être de
communication politique qui n'est à mon
avis vraiment pas la bonne c'est à dire
qu'on nie sol la menace dans une
temporalité qui est censée être celle de
l'exception au lieu d'affronter les
crises identitaires social de la menace
terroriste de la sécurité et peut-être
de les prendre à bras le corps par une
réponse qui est celle des libertés qui
est donc toujours beaucoup plus longue
qui est donc moins offensive que la
reprise en main sécuritaire mais qui
donne des réponses qui ont moins
correspondre à notre site et à notre
identité et notre histoire et j'ai eu
plaisir à lire justement l'humanisme
avec lequel finalement on retrouve
certains de nos acteurs qui se battent
au quotidien pour essayer de montrer que
le droit est avant tout un espace de
liberté un espace de protection alors
que de plus en plus la prolifération
lois sécuritaires comme sacré des droits
pénaux spéciaux des droits de la
sécurité ils sont profondément relatif
si on a eu les premières utilisées
notamment les infractions préventive
avec le délit d' entreprise terroriste
qui est qui qui ont qui ont été
complètement une bouleversement de nos
droits constitutionnels revélois c'est
passionnant parce que on est rentré
alors peut-être pas seulement là depuis
deux trois ans avec l'enchaînement de
ducobu depuis de la guerre en irak mais
conscient rajoute à ça le bouleversement
climatique on est dans une phase de
répétition de crises et donc c'est
intéressant de se dire que ce que les
algériens de bezina on peut pas rester
dans une exception permanente puisque il
va falloir s'adapter et s'habituer à
vivre des crises en répétition est ce
que vous faites cette analyse est
également oui je suis un peu d'accord
point de vue historique je crois qu'au
fond il ya toujours eu des crises nées
crise n'a plus aujourd'hui qu'avant oui
je pense pas que cinq ans simplement ce
qui est curieux c'est qu'on est et ce
qui est caractéristique c'est qu'on est
plus sensible aux crises et c'est ce que
vous disiez jardin où placer leur si
j'ose dire sans doute à cause de cette
mondialisation de l'information c'est ce
que c'est quand même frappant que les
informations particulièrement en france
commence mêmes continuent à montrer ce
qui ne marche pas c'est à dire ce qui
est
le bras tout suivi
le 11-septembre en direct pendant une
après-midi une soirée entière nous
étions planté devant votre télévision
voilà c'est cette saison je pense que
c'est le phénomène que vous décrivez
c'est à lui-même et même le lendemain
matin je me souviens que j'animais les i
j'animais l'édition spéciale à l'époque
ça ne nous rajeunit pas sur tf1 donc on
avait fait presque 24 heures dans des
centrales est autre chose c'est c'est
qu'il ya un écart de plus en plus grand
entre les faits je dirais pas la réalité
les faits et puis le ressenti ils
l'observent absolument des cadres avec
l'émotion qui est beaucoup plus grand si
grave c'est que c'est en france que
c'est triste à dire que cet écart et les
grands j'avais regardé en utilisant ses
talent exceptionnel c'est intéressant ce
que vous dites l'écart entre la réalité
et la perception et sa conduite en
février entre les fêtes j'avais j'ai
fait d'ailleurs un livre qui avait un
titre un petit peu holla holla puisque
cesse le titre était se sentir mal dans
une france qui va bien et est donc
c'était d'un côté je regardais dans les
enquêtes eurobaromètre qui pose la même
question dans les 27 pays de l'union
européenne
des questions sur
perception de l'avenir la perception des
par exemple des prestations sociales de
son pays et puis non justement non pas
l'arrêter mais les faits par exemple
quelle est la proportion de dans le
budget national des prestations sociales
est presque toujours la france est le
pays qui est le plus négatif alors que
prend l'exemple des prestations sociales
c'est le pays maintenant où elle
représente la plus forte part du public
et parce que finalement les mais le rôle
des médias de masse inde on en a parlé
avec le 11 septembre mais qui étaient là
aussi pour les attentats du 13 novembre
2015 ce sont les mêmes dans toutes les
sociétés occidentales donc cela pourquoi
cette différence française peut-être
alors mon single bien sûr la question
qui était posée ce qui est beaucoup plus
dur que de faire le constat et je pense
pas à mon enfant
tentative d'explication c'est que ça
passait à travers un problème français
peut-être un peu plus fort que dans des
pays voisins par exemple en allemagne
qui est la question de l'ascension
sociale c'est à dire que les des
français se sentent arrivé à 10 ont
passé la jeunesse arriver à peu près à
30 ans se sentent bloqués dans leurs
aspirations beaucoup plus que dans des
pays du nord ou que en allemagne et
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que quand on
voit le profil des électeurs du
rassemblement national
leur catégorie dominante c'est de 30 ans
à 55 ans c'est justement ce moment où on
est entré dans la vie active et vous
dirai dans presque tous les pays on ne
réalise pas tous ses rêves mais je pense
qu'en france il ya quelque chose d'un
peu plus durer c'est une d'ailleurs des
explications
est ce que dans le résultat des
élections législatives ya cette peur
dont on parle depuis que je pense que
tout ce qu'on vient de dire c'est que
aujourd'hui on est en pleine irrationnel
sur beaucoup de ces élections
présidentielle qu'aux législatives
elles ne sont quand même pas marqué de
raison que ce soit avec un petit air ou
avec un grand r franchement on est dans
les c'est ce que j'ai d'écrire mon lit
mais de manière générale nous sommes
devant irrationnel c'est à dire non
seulement dans l'émotion mais aussi dans
cette espèce en politique de qui on l'a
vu dans d'autres périodes
depuis 250 ans mais qui est que la
protestation
l'hostilité
le dédain
prend le dessus sur toute autre
considération et tout ça ce sont des
points qui naturellement ne permettent
absolument pas de construire de la
politique ça permet simplement délire
des jambes parce qu'on a des modes de
scrutin qui permettent à la
proportionnelle au majoritaire délire en
l'occurrence c'est ce qu'on a fait mais
ensuite et c'est tout le problème qu'on
voit le d'un doublé hier soir à gap
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors que qu'est-ce
que la période pourrait se prêter aux
conques asie la hausse qu'on voudrait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'une expression de
ce genre qui effectivement fait
qu'aujourd'hui et c'est bien l'assemblée
nationale est plus représentative ça
c'est clair mais qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
à partir du moment où ces votes ont été
faits sous l' empire encore une fois non
pas d'une démarche rationnelle
constructive et caetera et école porte
et il faut bien le dire par nos valeurs
fondamentales universel mais au
contraire par une démarche complètement
pourri mais irrationnelle tout bon s'il
ya aussi une part de responsabilité
politique je dès qu'il parle d'abord
sous la halle à nos émotions mais aucun
autre raison la décennie mais il est
tout à fait évident que
c'est une des grandes difficultés je
pense que quand on voit à partir les
choses ont beaucoup tourné dudu du temps
notamment de l'ue président sarkozy
quand on voit sur certains sujets que
que connaît bien avait le bras que je
traite dans mon livre sur les questions
de migration des migrations de
populations étrangères par exemple en
2010 2008 déjà avec la création du
ministère de l'identité nationale mais
quand même c'était écrit sur la face à
l'immigration
mais après en deux ans après le
président sarkozy fait un discours en
août 2010 dans lesquels il met en cause
l'immigrant douter et met en cause le
droit du sol et c'est comme ça on est on
est là engagé dans des positions qui
sont celles des politiques effectivement
qui sont partagés probablement
aujourd'hui par deux tiers de la
population et qui sont des positions qui
ces salades et grande difficulté ne
permettent pas de construire on le dit
en matière d'immigration ne permettent
pas de construire autre chose que de la
violence c'est à dire ceux qui sont pour
et ceux qui sont contre alors on on va
reparler de d'immigration mais là je
voudrais qu'on se concentre un petit peu
sur la la question de cette crise
sanitaire avec cette crise on a vécu
pendant 2 au rythme des conseils de
défense sanitaire 3 confinement plus ou
moins strictes peut-on pour autant
parler de dictature sanitaires on va en
débattre mais d'abord on fait le point
sur l'état d'urgence avec alexandre
poussin pour re bonsoir
alexandre donc cet état de gens
s'arrêtent on va être prêt si à la fin
du mois de juillet le gouvernement
prépare un nouveau projet de loi oui
précisément aujourd'hui nous vivons dans
l'état de le régime transitoire l'état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est à dire que
c'est un état d'urgence plutôt allégé ou
le premier ministre a quand même des
pouvoirs exceptionnels il peut limiter
des déplacements ça veut dire décider de
confinement au couvre-feu mais seulement
au niveau local il peut également
limiter notre notre utilisation des
transports fermer des établissements
recevant du public comme les restaurants
ou les bars interdire des rassemblements
et il peut en ce moment toujours
instaurer un pass sanitaires pour entrer
dans certains lieux d'ailleurs se passer
ni terre se passe vaccinale il est
toujours en vigueur pour les
établissements de santé est en effet
tous ces pouvoirs exceptionnels qui sont
accordés au gouvernement et bien ils
prennent fin le 31 juillet alors d'içi
là et bien l'exécutif planche sur un
nouveau projet de loi sanitaire qui
abandonnerait la majorité du dispositif
existant mais qui serait quand même
effectif pour éviter et bien une
nouvelle vague de l'épidémie écoutez la
porte parole du gouvernement libyen
grégoire sur la fise olive la
philosophie de ce nouveau texte
sanitaire n'est pas là sur passe
vaccinale état d'urgence et c'est
ce qui nous importe c'est de nous
assurer je dirais qu'on est en mesure
d'intervenir si nécessaire encore une
fois avec la mise en place de mesures de
freinage
si la situation je crois que c'est le
chic est important de et est amenée à
évoluer voire a dégénéré poste 31
juillet alors ce projet de loi sanitaire
il devait être présenté en conseil des
ministres ce mercredi le
de juin mais il ya un contexte politique
et compte tenu du résultat des élections
législatives et bien le conseil des
ministres a été annulé et donc la
présentation de cette nouvelle loi
qu'ovide a été reportée en tout cas ce
texte il est en ce moment examiné par le
conseil d'état la plus haute juridiction
administrative et le site d'informations
atlantico.fr a révélé à la version qui a
été livré au conseiller d'état et on
voit qu'on est vraiment sur des mesures
sanitaires beaucoup plus légère avec ce
texte le gouvernement pourrait seulement
imposer un pass sanitaires pour franchir
les frontières de l'hexagone de
l'outre-mer de la corse et puis ce
projet loi prolonge aussi l'autorisation
du fichier sidec qui rassemble les
résultats des tests qu vide et donc qui
liste les personnes contaminées donc
voilà on est vraiment sur une diminution
de la restriction des libertés en
matière sanitaire mais ces mesures
pourraient évoluer aussi en fonction de
la situation sanitaire actuelle et du
rebond épidémique car on le rappelle un
la semaine dernière le nombre de
nouveaux quatre corridas augmenté de 50%
merci alexandre anne charlène les b sens
et oui même démarche mais celle qui a
été fait pour l'état d'urgence anti
terroriste le 31 octobre 2017 a été
adoptée promulguer une loi qui a
prolongé
quatre des dispositions de l'état
d'urgence anti terroriste dans le droit
commun ensuite alors disons le aussi
sous le contrôle du juge mais par
exemple il ya des mesures d'assignation
à résidence ont été maintenus que soi et
oui mais vous venez pas jusqu'à dire
dictature sanitaires à propos des normes
de plus je vois on n'est pas du tout du
tout et je pense que il y avait une
justification complète ce qui a été la
tv je trouve que enfin tout le monde dit
que la france c'est plutôt face au virus
pas mal débrouillé et notamment grâce à
ces mesures mais s'est on voit bien le
fait que et c'est tout le sujet de votre
discussion glisse de ce qui était état
de crise est à d'exception juridique a
droit commun la présence droit commun et
on se lance dans si jamais il se passait
quelque chose là prévoit là mais ça veut
dire très clairement qu'au titre de la
liberté de l'égalité et ne l'oublions
pas de la fraternité reconnu par le
conte sectionnelles depuis maintenant
deux ans on en prendra 20 du coût absolu
de bézid ça pose quand même des
questions justement sur la prévention et
la répression c'est à dire que le droit
est normalement un outil de répression
c'est à dire qu'il est là pour arriver
au stade ultime le contrôle du juge est
normalement censé être un contrôle de
répression et donc multiplier les
législations de prévention de sécurité
pose nécessairement un problème
d'équilibré puisqu'on a notamment
beaucoup de collègues qui ont parlé
d'accoutumance à l'état d'urgence parce
qu'à partir du moment où on légifère sur
ce qui pourrait apparaître risqués sur
la sécurité des uns et des autres et
bien on peut tout à fait continuer à
prévenir toutes les situations et se
perdre finalement dans l'outil juridique
de la prévention qui a quand même ce
grand défaut de faire perdre la priorité
au droit à la liberté puisque c'est vrai
que on a parlé de dictature exécutive au
moins en tout cas de reprise en main
exécutive par la crise dans beaucoup de
nos démocraties la france n'a pas du
tout été isolé même l'allemagne qui a
une culture profondément parlementaire a
géré cette crise de l'aco vide avec le
gouvernement avec notamment les
exécutifs même régionaux et ces
questions là prouve bien que dans les
périodes de crise on a besoin d'une
décision unilatérale mais toute la
mesure est celle de la temporalité il ne
faut pas que ces états devient d etat
permanent notamment parce que
l'équilibré se défausse et l'état de la
part des excuses et loi sanitaire sont
sont passés devant les dents les
parlementaires alors c'est toute la
question c'est dur la procédure a été
respectée mais dans des conditions
d'urgence là aussi qui finalement ne
sont pas particulièrement respectueuses
de l'état droit puisque on fait de la
procédure d'urgence on convoque le
parlement en 48 heures et on annonce
même l'issue de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel avant que ce dernier eut
le temps se réunir donc on a
finalement un état droit qui a marché
sur la tête pendant quelques semaines
parce que ça la loi contre l'état de
droit la marge de
l'état d'urgence contre l'état de droit
c'est à dire que pour préserver l'état
de droit on a besoin d'une urgence qui
ne soit pas de l'ordre de la coutume il
ya une question qui est de l'ordre plus
sociologique mais qui nous a tous
frappés c'est quand même notre capacité
collective à accepter d'être enfermé
lors du premier confinement
alors peut-être pour de bonnes raisons
ces frappes personne n'était allé
manifester dans la rue pour dire on a
cette capacité était encore plus forte
dans des pays pourtant jugé
indisciplinés comme l'espagne comme
l'italie il est comme mêmes comme la
grèce italie le précurseur absolument et
pourquoi et je crois que si l'on était
même meilleur que nous a beaucoup de
points de vue et parce que les hommes
politiques dans ces pays n'ont
absolument pas prêté attention aux
antilles vax et je pense qu'il ya eu une
responsabilité très grand lemps france
creed je n'ai pas digéré au début de ma
carrière j'étais de jeu faisait
justement de l'épidémiologie avec daniel
charte du sabre ou si donc je connais un
petit peu c'est chose de voir
macron vise à rendre visite pendant
trois heures au professeur raoul guise
était le plus mauvais signal qu'on
pouvait envoyer c'était en italie ou en
espagne
les politiques ont été clairs s'étaient
ils ont été clairs sur la vaccination et
une fois qu'on éclaire la population
suit plus facilement là ça crée un doute
très fort il ya une sorte de
d'hésitation est ce que après tout même
la recette je ne sais plus ce que
d'autres
marc quand on connaît maintenant les
ravages quand même une intelligence
collective du temps je trouve puisque si
les premiers mois les premières semaines
et bien finalement 7 cette sociologie
dont vous parliez qui a fait qu'on
accepte finalement la décision elle
était proportionnée à la menace il ya un
principe qui est cardinal endroits et
sur lequel repose tout nos libertés ces
principes de proportionnalité et on a
bien vu que le peuple français a accepté
un temps et que plus la menace
apparaissaient moins forte moins
importante lui l'habitude de vivre avec
le virus devait devenir prégnante et
bien plus le peuple n'a plus accepté ces
restrictions donc ça prouve bien que
l'urgence et l'état d'exception à une
temporalité qui se voit dans
l'acceptabilité sociale finalement alors
on va ouvrir un autre chapitre sur
autour d'un cas d'école qui est quand
même très intéressant sur ce thème des
libertés publiques l'éthicien va revenir
sur cette volonté du maire de grenoble
eric piolle d'autoriser le burqini à la
piscine municipale mardi le conseil
d'état a finalement retoqué ce nouveau
règlement intérieur oui là le conseil
d'état a estimé que ce nouveau règlement
des piscines municipales à à grenoble
était une dérogation très ciblées
destinées à satisfaire une revendication
religieuse j'insiste bien sur ce mot
religieux parce que ça va être vraiment
au coeur de ce que je vais développer à
présent et le conseil d'état estimé
aussi que c'était de nature à affecter
le bon fonctionnement du service public
et l'égalité de traitement des usagers
dans des conditions portant atteinte au
principe de neutralité des services
publics alors dans la foulée le ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin qui avait
lui-même un saisi la préfecture de
l'isère s'en est réjoui sur twitter je
ne voulais pas tout son tweet mais
l'idée force c'est que c'est une
victoire pour la loi séparatisme pour la
laïcité et au delà pour toute la
république car comment a réagi
le maire europe ecologie les verts de
l'udc de grenoble wheeler eric piolle à
rejeter bien sûr en bloc l'accusation de
communautarisme il a dit qu'il était
universaliste attaché à l'eau à la loi
de 1905 et c'est là tout le problème en
fait qu'il ya au coeur de cette
polémique sur le burqini les intentions
d eric piolle ne sont pas énoncé de
façon honnête pourquoi parce que le au
lendemain de la décision du conseil
d'état il dit eric piolle on a montré
qu'il existe aujourd'hui plein de
maillot qu'on peut acheter à décathlon
sans vouloir faire de publicité avec des
jupettes certains ont envie de cacher
leurs corps et c'est leur droit ce n'est
pas du tout la question et c'est ce qui
gêne à mon avis dans ce type de
décisions c'était hypocrisie qui
consiste à balayer d'un revers de main
le biais religieux qui est pourtant
fondamental dans le port du burkini et
qui est souvent aussi quand même le fait
d'une majorité masculine qui veut voile
et le corps de la femme et qui sous
cette voie là c'est cet aspect de la
pudeur veut légitimer cette décision
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
le conseil d'état n'a pas à retoquer
l'intégralité de ce nouveau règlement et
non pas se réjouir parce que cette loi
est donc cette décision pardon du
conseil d'état n'est pas du tout
liberticide pourquoi parce que les
tenues de bain ajusté près du corps je
cite un sont permises faudra quand même
un peu nous expliquer les
caractéristiques de ajusté près du corps
et attention grand nouvelle le monokini
est autorisé parce que c'était aussi
dans le nouveau règlement
équilibré avec sa wii voilà donc là
c'est là qu'on voit quand même que cette
histoire de de liberté un de ceux de se
vêtir comme l'on souhaite est aussi une
affaire de moeurs a est d'habitude je ne
suis pas sûr que les femmes vont se
jeter les femmes grenobloise sans
soutien gorge pour aller se baigner dans
la piscine municipale
effectivement on verra jacques toubon
dans votre passé de défenseurs des 3
décembre 2018 vous aviez été saisis sur
lequel une femme musulmane musulmane en
burqini qui avaient été refusés à
l'entrée d'un parc aquatique c'est dans
la somme qu'est ce que vous aviez
conclure même moment je suis les
positions qui est reprise par le
défenseur des droits dominique baudis
avait déjà pris une décision moi j'ai
prise décision notamment sur sur
un parc public avec un grand bassin et
j'ai bien indiquer de manière très
simple que au titre de ce que l'on
appelle faussement la laïcité et était
en réalité la liberté de conscience est
ce que
les mots à contresens et à ce titre là
et apporté deux moments winnie est
strictement aucun inconvénient ce port
du burkini dans ces circonstances ne
posait aucun problème mais j'avais mis
moi j'avais fait un avis moi pour dire
que les municipalités qui l'avait qui
avait expulsé cette femme de se montrer
était en était en faute et le le très
bien administratif
avait n'avait pas été saisie par le par
le maire parce que en réalité dans cette
affaire la décision qui a été prise hier
par le conseil d'état ou avant-hier vous
savez elle est marquée du fait que entre
temps est intervenue la loi séparatisme
et le conseil d'état s'est appuyé sur la
halle au séparatisme pour faire cette
interdiction s'il n'y avait pas eu la
loi séparatisme on se serait trouvé dans
la situation de l'état de droit que
j'avais en 2018 et je pense que il n'est
pas sûr du tout que le tribunal
administratif et le conseil d'état est
annulé la décision je vous reposer la
question est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
prendriez la même décision ça chante la
loi sachant que la loi et a évolué et
oui oui parce que je prendrais pas parce
que je suis hostile à cette loi
séparatisme qui me paraît tomber
justement sous les critiques qu'on vient
de faire à ce que j'entends bien c'est
clair que c'est une loi est une loi qui
comporte quelque chose qui s'appelle le
délit d'opinion bon c'est le délit
d'opinion mais les jeux elle est passée
prosélytisme et ça c'est en parti
politique c'est là c'est parti le
conseil constitutionnel est en partie
pas parce que c'est un vrai pont je vous
interromps parce que je suis ce que je
dirai que ce jour avec la loi
séparatisme oui je serai magistrat
j'appliquerai naturellement la loi
séparatisme mais encore une fois les
vrais principes avant la loi séparatisme
qui à mon avis pose un vrai problème par
rapport à nos valeurs et à nos à nos
droits fondamentaux c'est que au titre
de la liberté de conscience le burkina
ne pose pas un problème et un parti dont
vous parlez pas troubles mais quand vous
parlez de tyrannie de l'identité
le burqini d'une certaine façon on
n'entre pas dans ce vivier total et non
pas du décès de comprends je suis moi je
suis je suis absolument et je le dis
dans mon bouquin complètement hostile à
toutes ces démarches qui cherche à
s'appuyer sur le cloud mentalisme qu'ils
soient islamistes ou qui soit autre
chose c'est tout à fait évident et que
et chercher à imposer mais là en
l'occurrence n'est pas une démonstration
de curgies ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
mettre ce qu'il faut mettre en cause et
de ce point de vue la décision du
conseil d'état n'est pas
n'est pas inopportune ce qu'il faut
mettre en cause et vous l'avez fait de
sa l'heure c'est que le sait le
comportement du maire ya de la part du
maire une position qui avait un but en
10 politique aux politiques visant alors
voilà et je pense que c'est pour ça et
lui qui échappe et aussi à l'état de
droit donc c'est moi qui sont la
décision du conseil d'état est fondé à
lyon
fondé sur l'absence de neutralité de la
prise de décision finalement par
l'autorité publique ce que met en cause
le conseil d'état c'est que le maire a
pris une position je dirai au delà de la
loi pour des raisons politiques et nous
enfin je dis je permets de dire nous
avec madame bezina parce que on approche
les questions de la même façon nous
voudrions revenir à une application du
droit et dans cette application du droit
il faut que tout le monde comprenne que
le burkini mais pas interdite voilà
parce que dans l'idée les gens le mur
qui était à dix noms voilà revenons à la
loi hervé leroy oui enfin je sais juste
anecdotique mais quand j'étais étudiant
il y avait des dans la rue on avait des
groupes avec des des sortes de cymbales
qui étaient habillés en noirs les arabes
personne n'aurait pensé à interdire aux
arrêts krishna pourtant c'est et deron
c'est une religion ils auront personne
n'aurait pu personne n'aurait pensé que
c'était du prosélytisme
donc il ya quand même une sensibilité
qui a
ouvert très attention à ce que on ne
peut à partir de ce type de démarches et
de tes positions prises à juste titre
par les juridictions dans la plus haute
juridiction administrative
on ne crée l'idée qu' il y ait un
certain nombre de choses qui sont au
titre de la liberté de culte la liberté
de conscience et cetera
non applicable c'est pas vrai nous
sommes dans un pays où
contrairement à tous les libelles qu'ils
ont publié depuis des années des zénètes
la lira ici tu es n'est pas une laïcité
organisé n'est pas une laïcité a permise
une laïcité interdite c'est ce sont des
mots qui ne vont pas avec le prince ce
qui a été posée en 1905 puis en 1900
1901 en 2000 en 1921 1922 parce qu'on
est toujours on oublie toujours les lois
subséquente à la loi de 2 de 1905 sur la
laïcité c'est la liberté de conscience
face à d'une barre une religion
dominante qui était la religion
catholique jusque là maintenant et face
à l'état qui avait été d'abord la
monarchie et puis la république et à
partir de là et à partir de là je pense
qu'aujourd'hui au titre de ces valeurs
universelles comme j'essaie de défendre
dans mon livre on a intérêt à défendre
cette conception de la laïcité et non
pas une conception policière pacifiant
l'immigration c'est le titre d'un de vos
chapitre à sion ça vous semble possible
ça hervé le bras de pacifier
l'immigration quand on voit là on a les
jambes du bürkli de
l'instrumentalisation politique du
burkina vous semble je pense que c'est
possible je vais prendre un exemple
étrangers
c'est dans les élections législatives
récentes en allemagne pourtant il ya un
parti qui est même encore plus extrême
droite l'afd aller en lice für
deutschland connais le rassemblement
national actuel est bien au cours de
cette campagne
la question de l'immigration a
pratiquement n'a pratiquement pas été
évoquée donc c'est possible et donc il
ya une responsabilité et je dois dire
que dans les eaux fondu dans les années
récentes
il ya les politiques ont joué avec le
feu à cette heure on dit c'est là les
médias mais une fois tu es politiques
entrent en jeu les médias suivent
inévitablement et ils ont beau moi je ne
suis plus occupé de cette aberration et
vous le qualifier comme tels d'ailleurs
dans votre livre du grand emplacement
mais j'ai vu sous mes yeux au moment où
la primaire de la droite a eu lieu
quatre des cinq candidats ont acquiescé
à ce risque absolument délirant et donc
là dedans je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
en france les politiques ont pris
cette question comme un moyen de faire
carrière et ce constat fait par les
autres a menti romandie je pense que ce
n'est pas si dur la même chose s'est
d'ailleurs produite au canada au canada
il ya eu une
certaine ya une vingtaine d'années la
question de l'immigration était assez
central et les partis politiques se sont
mis d'accord pour ne plus la mettre au
centre pour être prudent à ce sujet la
hem c'est à ce moment là que bon c'est
différent de la france mais la question
des accommodements raisonnables un
nombre de questions de ce genre là sont
apparus et ça dingue alors que le canada
est un des pays qui allaient plus forte
immigration au monde elle ne pose plus
ce genre de problème un document assez
viril de votre ancienne famille
politique ou dans votre famille c'est
clair que le club que
le rpr bd à la fin des années
90 2000 et les républicains aujourd'hui
c'est pas du tout la même chose sur ce
type de sujet et je parlais du tournant
notamment de 2008 2010 c'est clairement
clairement et je pense que
je le dis souvent
avec un sourire que désolé mais
chirac doit pas être très content là où
il est il compte y voit un certain
nombre de choses qui se disent à ce
sujet quand ils voient que le front
républicain a explosé est inexistant et
puis il ya quand même
100 90 % des cas le député du front
national il a été élu contre un député
qui défendait des valeurs qui sont
celles que se défend dans mon livre avec
le soutien de gens qui électeurs qui
étaient censés défendre les mêmes
valeurs et qui pourtant voté pour le
pour le candidat du front national 30 %
des cas c'est quand même et donc et donc
on voit bien on voit bien là que c'est
peut-être quand je suis le sujet le
chapitre j'ai écrit ce patient
l'immigration c'est peut-être là où il
faut le plus essayer de faire revenir ce
que je dis toulon bon livre la raison
avec un grand r mais franchement je
pense que et là monsieur le bras à
monsieur tous ceux qui qui qui travaille
là dessus l'ont toujours démontrée et
notamment sur le plan de la démographie
sur le plan de la fécondité par exemple
des femmes étrangères et enfin la vie
économique
le et je le traite la dame pour
expliquer que vient la fécondité des
femmes étrangères elle a rejoint la
fécondité des femmes européennes donc le
grand remplacement si c'est une
baliverne donc il faudrait rattacher la
question de l'immigration au ministère
de l'économie et pas omis son intérieur
par exemple mais il n'y a pas si
longtemps
du ministère du travail oui j'étais aux
affaires sociales et des affaires
sociales les sciences que c'était
beaucoup il le raisonnable et d'ailleurs
il y avait un certain calme c'est une
dérive et qui est comme quand on n'a
fait qu'y tout dernier m'a
transféré au ministère de l'intérieur
ces affaires d'intérêts quand on a fait
des affaires régaliennes alors que ce
sont des affaires culturelles sociales
et économiques merci encore je dois vous
dire c'est le titre de votre livre
jacques toubon livre publié aux éditions
stock merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce
débat